notre correspondant en russie jean
françois bélanger poursuit ce soir son
voyage à bord du transsibérien pour nous
faire découvrir ce pays sous un nouveau
jour
alors pour le premier arrêt de son
périple il lève le voile sur l'un des
secrets les mieux gardés de la période
soviétique
une catastrophe nucléaire dont presque
personne n'a entendu parler mais qui
continue de faire des victimes
notre étape du jour nous emmène près de
tcheliabinsk à 1500 km à l'est de moscou
c'est un endroit secret
tellement secret qu'il ne figurait
jusqu'à présent sur aucune carte
vestiges de l'ère soviétique
la ville de niort ce qu'est le complexe
nucléaire de maïak tout près l'avait à
l'époque même pas de nom et pour cause
on y fabriquait à l'abri des regards
le plutonium de la première bombe
atomique russe
il est encore aujourd'hui impossible de
s'en approcher aux yeux lorsque est
toujours une ville fermée le panneau à
l'entrée de l'agglomération est clair
les lieux sont interdits aux étrangers
c'est donc en périphérie de la ville que
nous rencontrons nadiejda coûté pauvres
la jeune femme se bat aujourd'hui contre
le secret et contre l'oubli car la
centrale de maïak
c'est aussi surtout le théâtre de la
première grosse catastrophe nucléaire de
l'histoire
trente ans avant tchernobyl c'était le
premier gros accident et bien sûr le
gouvernement n'était pas prêt ils ont
décidé de passer tout ça sous silence
en septembre 1957 une cuve de déchets
nucléaire explose et projette un nuage
radioactif sur une zone de 23 mille
kilomètres carrés près de 300000
personnes des alentours sont exposés aux
radiations
parmi elles le père et la grand mère de
d'attitude à tous de travailler à la
centrale nucléaire
tous deux sont morts d'un cancer le père
de nattes fda n'avait que 45 ans bien
sûr ce sont des victimes de la
catastrophe
mais personne n'a dit à mon père qu'il
avait le cancer ça devait rester secret
à sa mort ça a été très dur pour moi en
tout l'explosion force l'évacuation
d'une vingtaine de villages mais
beaucoup d'habitants ne seront re
logique des années après le drame
d'autres ne le seront jamais c'est le
cas du village de kara ball cas qui se
trouve toujours aujourd'hui dans la zone
contaminée
nadia et vient régulièrement pour
prendre des nouvelles de ses habitants
et ne peut s'empêcher de s'émouvoir de
leur triste sort le gritche ça me désole
tout ça parce que je connais la vérité
et je connais les conséquences il y à
des hommes plus contaminé d'autres mais
ses ondes les jeunes ne connaissent pas
contaminantes préféré qu'il n'y ait pas
d'enfants ici parce que c'est dont je
vais tenir tête quand just fontaine a
pris des cours de droit et offre
aujourd'hui ses services légaux
gratuitement aux habitants des zones
contaminées
des gens comme ci est la nasa nova qui
ont cultivé la terre toutes ces années
sans trop savoir sans trop avoir le
choix
j'espère passif s'ils attrapent au
mirail est à la raconte que tous les
habitants meurent jeunes dans le village
est presque tous du cancer
c'est le cas de sa fille regina morte à
6 ans d'un cancer du foie
elle était très joyeuse pleine de vie
client n'a même pas pleurer et elle
s'est battue jusqu'au bout
il est sûre elle ne comprenait pas ce
qui se passait elle n'avait que 6 ans le
cancer de sa fille est une conséquence
directe de la participation de sa
grand-mère au nettoyage des dégâts
radioactifs
elle aimerait obtenir une compensation
pour sa fille mais c'est une procédure
très complexe en cours la diège des as
déjà gagné quelques procès mais dans ce
cas ci les chances sont minces
la loi n'a pas prévu de compensation
pour les parents ayant perdu leurs
enfants aïcha si j'ai le sentiment d'une
grande injustice et je sens que j'ai le
devoir de la combattre du moins je dois
essayer aux dédits de ce job des fourmis
le drame pour les habitants de la région
c'est que la catastrophe nucléaire de
1957 est loin d'être un cas isolé
l'idée c'est radioactifs ont été
déversés à plusieurs reprises dans
l'environnement
s'il y a qu'à certains endroits le long
de cette rivière la radiation atteint
des niveaux sans soit supérieur à la
normale
une vingtaine de villages s'étalent le
long des berges de la rivière tedjar
comme un chapelet d'injustice les
habitants de bodo call mac par exemple y
puisaient leur eau potable
la rivière servait aussi à abreuver les
bêtes et irriguer les terres aux
alentours dans les années qui ont suivi
les déversements radioactifs
des barrières ont été érigées pour
couper l'accès aux cours d'eau
contaminée ce qui n'empêche toutefois
pas les enfants d'y accéder ou llory
potapov le s'en souvient très bien quand
on était plus jeunes la clôture avait
déjà on se rendait toujours à la rivière
pour s'y baigner y pêcher y boire de
l'eau yuri a aujourd'hui un lymphome en
phase terminale comme sa mère avant lui
le cancer aura bientôt raison de nuit le
deuxième salon funéraire a ouvert ses
portes récemment au village
le premier ne suffisait plus à la
demande vladislav thierry panov y
travaille depuis peu il n'a que 41 ans
et pourtant il n'en finit plus
d'enterrer ses anciens camarades de
classe
s'il craque dans ma classe il y avait 26
élèves
à ma connaissance il n'y en a plus que
cinq ans vit maintenant tous les autres
sont morts
ça fait trois ans que je travaille ici
et on ne manque pas d'ouvragé
en général les gens meurent à à 40,50
cac
pichard
très peu d'habitants pourtant songé à
quitter la région
en cause l'absence de moyens le manque
d'alternatives
le fatalisme aussi qui les pousse à
retourner pêcher dans la rivière
empoisonnée l'émergent distille ont été
depuis décontaminées alors à quoi bon
s'inquiéter surtout qu'ils n'y peuvent
rien changer
les habitants des zones contaminées
touche une messe compensation financière
mais seulement à condition d'y rester
autant de règles absurdes autant
d'injustice contre lesquels nadiejda a
décidé de lutter et 12 pouces est le
même sauf mar aussi je fais sans mémoire
de mes parents que je n'ai pas pu aider
favey die pour mon père qui est mort
dans des conditions horribles gros comme
des choses
lutter contre l'injustice une mission
qu'elle s'est donnée une promesse faite
à l'adolescente qu'elle a un jour été
l'adolescente trop jeune en deuil et
demain notre voyage entre elle nous
emmène voir les belles de sibérie un
voyage en compagnie de recruteurs qui
sillonne à bord du transsibérien les
régions les plus reculées du pays à la
recherche de la perle rare
la future top model qui éveillera les
photographes à paris ou new york et je
vous invite à consulter le carnet de
voyage de jean françois avec de
magnifiques photos des commentaires et
des compléments d'informations rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
que vous voyez à l'écran